hacer muñecos de Vladimir Putin en forma
de bailarinas es una forma de activismo
para Katia
es como un recuerdo para demostrar que
Putin es una figura lamentable
no da miedo en absoluto
ella siguió de cerca los acontecimientos
en Rusia en particular los avances del
grupo Wagner en el sur del país y luego
su repentina retirada
era obvio que algo así iba a ocurrir
que estallaría un conflicto entre este
grupo criminal Porque nuestro país está
gobernado por bandidos forman un gran
grupo criminal organizado y los
conflictos iban a estallar
[Música]
se mudó a París hace un año con su hijo
arseni de 17 años
como artista y activista política corría
peligros en Moscú y le preocupaba que
arseni pudiera ser llamado a las filas
del ejército ruso
su marido Denis y su hija de 23 años
Sasha se unieron a ellos unos meses
después
se sienten Afortunados de haber
encontrado seguridad en Francia pero las
noticias de la rebelión del grupo Wagner
reavivaron sus preocupaciones por su
familia y amigos en casa
por supuesto estábamos asustados
pensamos que una vez más iba a morir
gente
pero yo estaba seguro de una cosa que no
iba a matar a Putin
ya toda mi vida Putin ha sido presidente
no conozco formas de vida alternativas
diseño gráfico y está a punto de empezar
un nuevo trabajo en Francia
Rusia tiene una cultura muy rica y hay
muchos grandes proyectos de arte
contemporáneo pero hoy en día no puedo
hacer planes a largo plazo porque todo
cambia muy deprisa
mientras Rusia prosigue su guerra contra
Ucrania y su familia como los miles de
rusos que han llegado recientemente a
Francia viven día a día sin poder volver
a casa por ahora